hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live bachmut vor dem Krieg war das eine
kleine Stadt im Osten der Ukraine mit
70.000 Menschen Touristen kamen auch
gerne wegen des bekannten örtlichen
Weinguts jetzt ist bachmut ein
Schlachtfeld mit der Stadt Solidar
bildet bachmut die Verteidigungslinie
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte würde sie
brechen würde das für die Russen den
Vormarsch in weite Teile des Ostens
leichter machen der britische
Geheimdienst meldet heute Fortschritte
der Russen in der Region demnach sei
Solidar fast komplett eingenommen
und der ukrainische Präsident selenski
äußert sich zu der Situation in der in
der in der Region sagt alles sei völlig
zerstört es gäbe Zitat fast kein Leben
mehr das gesamte Gebiet bei Solidar sei
von den Leichen der Besatzer und Narben
der Angriffe bedeckt so sieht Wahnsinn
aus sagt selenski der Kampf um Mahmut
und um Solidar heute bei uns das Thema
und die Frage damit verbunden ist das
ein Rückschlag für die Ukraine darüber
wollen wir heute sprechen und ihr könnt
Fragen stellen direkt im Stream
natürlich mit kommentieren oder per Mail
eure Fragen schicken denn unser Experte
der mit uns durch diese Sendung heute
zusammen geht ist general ade Egon Rams
schönen guten Abend
guten Abend Frau jung Russland soll also
in der Region umbachmut und vor allem in
Solidar weiter vorgedrungen sein wie
realistisch ist das denn das Russland
tatsächlich sogar Solidar eingenommen
hat
es gibt von der Seite der Ukrainer in
dieser Richtung bisher keine Bestätigung
obwohl das was der Präsident gesagt hat
ja ausgesprochen negativ klingt
richtig ist dass die russische Seite in
den letzten Wochen die Kräfte in diesem
Raum verstärkt hat reguläre russische
Streitkräfte aber richtig ist auch dass
man wie Korsettstangen in die russischen
Streitkräfte die Gruppe Wagner
eingezogen hat und die Gruppe Wagner ist
für ihre Hartnäckigkeit aber auch für
ihre menschenverachtende Kampfweise
bekannt wir haben auch aktuelle Bilder
einfach Mut und die Lage fasst uns jetzt
Keilriemen in einem Beitrag zusammen
seit Monaten wird das Gebiet rund um die
Stadt bachmut von schweren Kämpfen
zermürft doch in den vergangenen Tagen
spitzt sich die Situation noch einmal zu
ukrainische Ärzte und Sanitäter kommt
kaum mit der Versorgung von Verletzten
Soldaten hinterher viele sterben
es ist zu traurig denn trotz der
Verluste des Feindes und des Heldentums
unserer Kämpfer haben wir auch Verluste
natürlich tut es weh wenn es nicht
möglich ist sie zu retten
[Musik]
in seiner Ansprache Montagnacht gab sich
der ukrainische Präsident selensky
kämpferisch bachmut hält durch sagte er
und beschrieb die russischen Angriffe
als konstanten Terror
was wollte Russland dort gewinnen alles
ist völlig zerstört es gibt fast kein
Leben mehr und tausende ihrer Leute sind
verloren das ganze Land in der Nähe von
Solidar ist mit Leichen der
Eindringlinge bedeckt und von den
Schlägen gezeichnet so sieht Wahnsinn
aus
das britische Verteidigungsministerium
berichtet heute das russische Truppen
und Söldner der Gruppe Wagner nördlich
von bachmut wahrscheinlich einen
Großteil der Stadt Solidar unter ihre
Kontrolle gebracht hätten die Region um
bachmut gilt als strategisch wichtig die
Stadt liefert gute
Verteidigungsmöglichkeiten und im
Untergrund gibt es viele Minen und
Tunnelsysteme
von konstanten Terror spricht der
Präsident wir haben es eben im Beitrag
gehört also auch am kämpfen für Russland
Söldner der wagnergruppe können Sie uns
ein bisschen genauer erläutern was ist
die Taktik im Moment von Seiten
Russlands dort in der Region
also für diese für die Russen ist dieser
Bereich ausgesprochen wichtig die Russen
hatten ja dieses Gelände bereits in
sicheren Besitz bevor die Angriffe von
Yakis aus nach Osten vorgetragen wurden
und die ukrainische Streitkräfte haben
dort ja ich sage mal zwischen September
und Dezember relativ große Erfolge
erzielt der ukrainische Angriff in diese
Richtung ist zum Stehen gekommen die
Russen haben ihre Kräfte verstärkt zum
Teil durch personalverstärkung zum Teil
auch durch neue Truppenteile und das
bedeutet dass die Russen in diesem
Bereich ein Schwerpunkt sehen wachmut
ist nicht nur wegen seiner Minen und
seiner Stollen interessant sondern
bachmodus auch eine Verkehrsdrehscheibe
und damit für die Logistik auch der
russischen Seite entsprechend wichtig
das heißt für diesen Knotenpunkt in
Besitz hat hat die Möglichkeit weiter
nach Westen beispielsweise Richtung
Kameras vorzustoßen und das würde dann
einen Teil der ukrainischen Erfolge die
sie im Herbst und bis in den
Winterjacken erzielt haben wieder zu
nicht machen und das wäre ausgesprochen
traurig und bedauerlich weil dann die
Menschenleben die dort geopfert worden
sind auch ukrainische Menschenleben
letztendlich geopfert worden wären ohne
dass die entsprechenden Geländegewinne
und Erfolge sich entsprechend ergeben
würden von daher eine kritische Zeit
eine kritische Lage vor allen Dingen
eine kritische Lage unter dem
Gesichtspunkt dass damit ein Teil des
Angriff schons den die Ukraine in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten gezeigt haben
damit verloren ginge und möglicherweise
durch die Russen sogar umgekehrt würde
wir sprechen gleich weiter bekommen noch
weitere Analyse von ihnen gehen jetzt
aber noch kurz 200 km weiter nördlich im
Land nach hakiv denn dort gab es heute
Besuch aus dem Westen Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock war dort in Rake eben
ganz nah an der russischen Grenze auch
in der Vergangenheit unter heftigsten
Beschuss dann aber geriet die Offensive
dort ins Stocken die ukrainischen
Truppen haben die Russen die Ukraine
haben die Russen dort vertrieben und für
uns live in hakiv dort wo also die
Außenministerin unterwegs war ist Tim
Kröger zu nehmen können wir jetzt
schalten hallo Tim
und er ist gleich wieder bei uns denn
wir wollen natürlich wissen was es heute
passiert bei diesem Besuch in rakiv von
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock und
Tim muss auch wieder bei uns Tim kannst
du uns berichten anderen
Lauf des Tages am Nachmittag erst raus
nachdem sie abgereist war dass sie
überhaupt dort war was war das für ein
Besuch
genau dieser Besuch wurde im Vorfeld
geheim gehalten weil das natürlich schon
ein sicherer heizrisiko ist hierher zu
reisen das war ein durchaus
freundschaftlicher Besuch denn Annalena
Babak die deutsche Außenministerin und
die ukrainischer ministerkollege kennen
sich gut und deswegen hat Kollege sie
dann auch hierher eingeschlagen die sind
zusammen mit dem Zug aus Kiel hierher
gefahren und dann hat sich im Grunde
eine Lena Bernburg hier die Folgen des
Krieges angeschaut also beispielsweise
ein Umspannwerk was vor kurzem erst von
russischen Raketen zerstört worden ist
sie waren in einer Schule in einer
werbestube dort ähm der hat sich eine
Kinderklinik angeschaut und sie waren
einem in einem Stadtviertel hier das
ganz besonders zerstört worden ist von
russischen Raketen dazu muss man wissen
dass rakelt diese zweitgrößte Stadt in
der Ukraine vor allem kurz nach Beginn
des Krieges im Februar vergangenen
Jahres eines der Hauptziele der Russen
war das ähm hier also sehr stark mit
Raketen reingehalten worden ist die
Menschen die haben sehr gelitten die
Stadt war geärgert und wurde dann am
Ende aber eben doch befreit dass alles
hat sich Annalena berberkir heute
innerhalb von nur vier Stunden
angeschaut und sie ist natürlich nicht
ganz mit leeren Händen gekommen die hat
40 Millionen mitgebracht hier für die
Stadt für die Minenräumung für die
bessere Internetversorgung für
Generatoren auch deswegen weil eben die
Energieversorgung die immer noch ein
Problem ist wenn man aber möchte dann
kann man in diesen Besuch auch noch
etwas mehr hinein interpretieren du hast
es gesagt Haki fliegt nur wenige Meter
entfernt von der russischen Grenze und
vielleicht war das eben heute hier auch
ein Zeichen an den russischen
Präsidenten Wladimir Putin das eben
Deutschland in Vertretung von berberbach
hier weiterhin fester an der Seite der
Ukraine steht und genau so hat sich dann
auch am Ende Ihres Besuchs im Bahnhof
von
ihrem Statement gesagt
noch eine Frage zum Schluss weil ich es
auch häufig in den Kommentaren lese hier
wird häufig über die Panzerlieferungen
geschrieben viele unserer Userinnen und
User Fragen auch nach dem Leopard der
Kampfpanzer den wir nicht liefern wir
haben aber letzte Woche schon gesprochen
denn Deutschland hatte Schützenpanzer
zugesagt der Ukraine waren denn die
Waffenlieferung von Deutschland aus dem
Westen auch Thema heute
absolut das wurde auch bestätigt wie
gesagt die beiden sind ja mit dem Zug
von Kiew nach Kiew gefahren das dauert
mehrere Stunden da hatten die die
Möglichkeit dann über solche
Waffenlieferungen zu sprechen allerdings
hat Anna-Lena baerbock hier jetzt noch
keine feste Zusage für die Lieferung
solcher Kampfpanzer gemacht
sie hat sich aber eben die Folgen des
Krieges angeguckt sie hat gesehen wie
die Menschen leiden und es könnte
natürlich sein dass das durchaus noch
mal neuen Schwung in die Diskussion um
die Lieferung von deutschen Kampfpanzern
an die Ukraine bringt ihr Amtskollege
Kollege jedenfalls hat noch mal
ordentlich Druck gemacht heute er hat
gesagt dass er eigentlich davon ausgeht
dass diese Kampfpanzer geliefert werden
und das die Bundesregierung in ihrem
Inneren eigentlich wissen dass so eine
Entscheidung fallen muss zugunsten von
Kampfpanzern und er hat auch noch mal
gewarnt er hat gesagt diese Entscheidung
darf einfach jetzt nicht mehr so lange
auf sich warten lassen ganz einfach weil
hier jeden Tag in der Ukraine Menschen
sterben
Einschätzung von Tim Krüger live in
hakiv in der Ukraine vielen Dank
und bei uns ist jetzt für die weitere
Analyse wieder general ade Egon Rams und
das Thema Waffenlieferung das wird uns
auch in diesem Stream noch beschäftigen
dazu komme ich auf jeden Fall auch noch
ich sehe auch eure Fragen hier dazu aber
wollen wir kurz noch einmal auf die Lage
in bachmut und Solidar wie zum Anfang
unserer Sendung auch zu sprechen kommen
Herr Rams die ukrainische Vize
Verteidigungsministerin sagte russland
habe in Solidar eine große Zahl von
sturmgruppen in den Kampf geworfen so
nennt sie ist und drücke buchstäblich
auf den Leichen seiner eigenen Soldaten
vor setze massiv Artillerie
Raketenwerfer und Mörser ein und jetzt
kommt der Punkt treffe dabei seine
eigenen Soldaten wie ist diese
ukrainische Aussage einzuschätzen warum
sollte dann Russland wissenschaftlich
die eigenen Leute auch immer wieder
treffen
also ich habe das eigentlich so
verstanden dass sie dabei die Leichen
russischer gefallener Soldaten treffen
die durch die russischen Streitkräfte
nicht mitgenommen oder zurückgeführt
worden sind das ist der eine Teil dabei
ob sie dabei auf ihre eigenen lebenden
Soldaten schießen seine zweite Frage
aber es passt eigentlich ein bisschen zu
dem Stil der Gruppe Wagner die Gruppe
Wagner ist in diesen Dingen absolut
rücksichtslos das kann man bei dem
Führer ab und zu auch aufgrund seiner
Äußerungen
merken und hören und es ist auch bekannt
dass die Gruppe Wagner vor wenigen
Wochen frisch nach in die Ukraine
gebrachte Rekruten ohne Ausbildung
eingesetzt hat das heißt es geht einfach
nur darum militärische Erfolge zu
erzielen koste es was es wolle koste es
auch eigene Leben kostet auch eigene
Soldaten das ist die Rücksichtslosigkeit
man muss die Gruppe Wagner so sieht dass
sie praktisch mit den anderen russischen
Truppenteilen gemeinsam kämpft und ich
vergleiche diese Gruppe mal mit Blick
auf die Aktionen die sie dort betreiben
um dort voranzukommen wie Korsettstangen
die dann die anderen Teile der
russischen Streitkräfte entsprechend
mitnehmen und mitführen sollen man muss
sich auf diese Grausamkeiten bei dieser
Gruppe einstellen das muss man wissen
das muss man entsprechend in der Lage in
die Lage Beurteilung mit einbeziehen und
von daher wird der Kampf in dieser
gleichen Art und Weise grausam wir
geführt ist in der Form weitergehen und
es geht Wagner oder pauschkin nicht um
irgendwelche ich sage das mal
berücksichtnahme auf irgendwelche
Verluste das geht ihm nur um den
militärischen Erfolg
bei diesen grausamen kämpfen fragen sich
natürlich auch Userinnen und User wie
Etienne maruff hier wie viele Soldaten
haben die Ukrainer noch und wie viele
Soldaten haben die Russen noch
alles eine Frage für beide Seiten die
ich nicht beantworten kann wir wissen
dass aufgrund der Rekrutierung die im
vierten Quartal stattgefunden hat in
Russland viele neue Soldaten man spricht
von etwa 300.000 für den Krieg in die
Ukraine gezogen worden sind teilweise
unvorbereitet in die Ukraine entsandt
worden sind teilweise ausgebildet worden
sind die ukrainische Seite gibt zwar
einen Teil ihrer Verluste zu und
verkündet das auch offen im Netz oder
auch in den Nachrichten aber ob diese
Zahlen richtig sind es ebenfalls nicht
überprüfbar die Anfangszahlen bei den
ukrainischen soldatenlagen bei 270 bis
290.000 sie haben Verluste ich schätze
das so ein dass die Verluste der
russischen Seite etwa doppelt so hoch
sind wie dieser Ukrainer wobei die
Ukraine selber wenn sie zahlen angibt im
Verhältnis zwischen ukrainischen
gefallenen oder Verwundeten und
russischen Verwundeten den Faktor fünf
einrechnet also bei uns sind sagt die
Ukraine etwa 20.000 Soldaten gefallen
oder verwundet und dann sind das auf der
russischen Seite 100.000 diese Zahlen
sind nicht verifizierbar und das wird
eine Frage sein die irgendwann später
nach dem Krieg vielleicht beantwortet
werden kann wenn man einen
entsprechenden Übersee einen
entsprechenden Übersicht hat selbst das
Installation vom Roten Kreuz ist in
dieser Richtung ich sage das mal
vorsichtig
mangelhaft oder gar nicht informiert von
daher eine schwierige Frage die nicht zu
beantworten ist und wie realistisch ist
dann eine weitere Einberufung in von
Seiten Russlands also um da noch mehr
Menschen rekrutieren zu können
also wenn der Krieg wenn der Krieg aus
russischer Perspektive nicht die
strategischen Ziele erreicht und so wie
die russische Regierung und Wladimir
Putin sich zur Zeit verhalten werden sie
vor keiner Rekrutierung zurückschrecken
das einzige was sie im Augenblick ein
bisschen abhält ist das Thema general
mobil machen weil man offensichtlich
davor in Russland Angst hat dass man
damit ich sag mal Widerstände in
Russland selber erzeugen könnte und das
wäre schlecht dann für die russische
Regierung und für Wladimir Putin wenn
Widerstand in Russland sich entsprechend
weiterentwickeln würde es hat in
Verbindung mit den mit den Toten die am
neuesten Tage entstanden sind
entsprechende Demonstrationen in den
Bereichen gegeben wo diese Soldaten
herkam von daher ist es nicht mehr ganz
so ruhig in Russland wie es noch vor
zwei drei Monaten gewesen ist
wir bekommen ganz besonders viele Fragen
gerade im Stream zu den
Panzerlieferungen insbesondere zum
Leopard deswegen möchte ich diesen
Komplex jetzt mal nach vorne ziehen eine
Frage hier mal stellvertretend
rausgreifen die kam von Arthur Laumann
per Mail er fragt sich wie erklären Sie
sich die zögerliche Haltung vor allem
der SPD wenn es um Waffenlieferungen
geht wo doch jedem klar ist dass die Leo
zwei Panzer schnellstmöglich geliefert
werden müssen was bezweckt die Regierung
damit immer wieder hinter den Tatsachen
herzulaufen
also ich möchte erstmal eine Anmerkung
machen wir reden immer von Leopard 2 die
Ukraine hat zu Anfang des Krieges nach
Kampfpanzern gefragt und weil Leopard 2
hat Deutschland ein Problem wir müssten
etwa 330 haben wir haben nur 280 das
heißt uns fehlen 50 wir leben also nicht
im Überfluss in dieser Frage dass das
erste was man wissen muss zweite Aussage
zu diesem Thema lassen Sie uns über
Leopard allgemein also auch über den
Leopard 1 reden die Industrie hat etwa
100 oder sogar noch eine einige mehr auf
ihren Höfen stehen die theoretisch
relativ schnell geliefert werden könnten
und die auch die Ukraine möglicherweise
weniger Probleme bereiten würden einfach
aus dem Grunde weil man für die Leopard
eins keine separate zumindest für Wanne
Triebwerk keine separate
Versorgungskette aufbauen müsste wir
haben die Gefahren geliefert wir haben
Bergepanzer geliefert beide haben
dasselbe Fahrgestell wie der Leopard 1
und wir haben Leopard 1,5 das ist die
modernste Version des Leopard 1 die
Bundeswehr genutzt hat wie gesagt bei
der Industrie stehen
diese Gefechte die dort geführt werden
sind ohne Kampfpanzer nicht entscheidend
zu gewinnen das ist die entscheidende
Aussage dabei und von daher wäre es
sinnvoll auch kurzfristig oder so
schnell wie möglich Leopard Kampfpanzer
in die Ukraine zu liefern wenn man sich
entscheidet mal dazu liefen zu liefern
wie es ja letzte Woche erfolgt ist
nachdem die Amerikaner gesagt haben wir
liefern Bradley nachdem macron der
französische Präsident gesagt hat wir
liefern AMS sehen was ja auch eine Art
Kampfpanzer ist wenn auch nur ein Spiel
Panzer wobei das nur vielleicht sogar
schon falsch ist dann muss man diesen
zweiten Schritt einfach auch gehen denn
der wirkverbund zwischen Panzer und
Panzergrenadieren ist das was Kampfkraft
und gefechtswert bringt und das eine für
sich und das andere für sich bringt im
Prinzip relativ wenig dass sein Nachteil
warum die Regierung so zögerlich ist
kann ich nicht beantworten ist eine
Frage die sich mir in der Antwort
verschließt schlicht und einfach
verschließt aus dem Grunde weil ich
selber schon paar Monaten gesagt habe
wir sollten Schützenpanzer und
Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine liefern und
diese Forderung von meiner Seite
wiederhole ich sie wird auch von vielen
Politikern sei es Frau stark Zimmermann
sei es zum Teil aus dem aus der Partei
der Grünen wenn ich anderen Hofreiter
denke wird diese diese Forderung
ebenfalls gestellt und ich halte es für
sinnvoll es kommt immer das Argument mit
dem Alleingang da rein wir sind machen
keine Alleingänge in dieser Richtung
sondern der eine X-10 beispielsweise hat
eine Waffe als Kanone die im Prinzip im
Prinzip von Kaliber vielleicht nicht von
der Leistungsfähigkeit her der Waffen
des Leopard 1 entspricht und da stelle
ich mir die Frage wo ist da der
Unterschied auch wenn in der Politik zum
Teil leider auch in den Medien dann
plötzlich der Begriff eines leichten
Panzers gebraucht wird für den A610
Panzer bleibt Panzer in dem Falle und es
geht dabei nicht um Gewicht sondern es
geht um Wirkung
es gibt jetzt auch Berichte das
Großbritannien in Erwägung zieht den
Kampfpanzer Challenger 2 zu schicken
wäre das denkbar ihrer Meinung nach
also ist seit etwa 20 Stunden gibt es
diese Informationen also gestern dass
die Briten darüber nachdenken ich habe
bisher von der britischen Regierung noch
keine offizielle Verlautbarung gehört
das kam wenn man Kenntnisstand richtiges
über einen anderen nachrichtenkanals
kein News von daher bin ich da mit dem
Augenblick noch vorsichtig es könnte
aber durchaus sein dass das ein Tor
Opener wäre also ein Türöffner wäre
genauso wie die imx-10 die macron
zugesagt hat und auf diese Art und Weise
dann in diese Panzer Debatte Bewegung
reinkommt und ich verweise darauf dass
ich die
Ukraine Hilfsgruppe oder keine
Kontaktgruppe am 20 Januar und der
Führung des amerikanischen
Verteidigungsministers wieder ein
Rammstein treffen wird und
möglicherweise ist es dann tatsächlich
eine Möglichkeit dort entsprechende
Entscheidung zu treffen aber ich möchte
noch mal eine Aussage des ukrainischen
Außenministers Kopierer aufgreifen der
schlicht und einfach gesagt hat jeder
Tag wo die Sachen später kommen die
Waffen später kommen kostet Leben in der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung bei
ukrainischen Soldaten
ist eigentlich das was ein sehr
nachdenklich stimmen sollte und wo man
vielleicht auf andere Dinge dann keine
Rücksicht mehr nehmen sollte würden sie
uns vielleicht noch mal zwei Sätze mehr
zu dem Challenger 2 sagen also ist das
ein richtig schwerer Kampfpanzer wie
unterscheidet der sich von anderen
also der Challenger 2 ist ein Panzer der
ist entwickelt worden Ende der 80er
Anfang der 90er Jahre er ist für mein
Kenntnisstand richtiges 97,98 in die
britische Streitkräfte eingeführt worden
hatte zunächst eine Kanone mit einem
gezogenen Lauf die hat man dann
hinterher umgerüstet im Prinzip auf
dieselbe Kanone wie sie der Leopard 2
hat eine Glattrohrkanone man hat auch
ein anderes Triebwerk in diesem Panzer
eingebaut nämlich auch wieder ein
deutsches MPU Triebwerk hier ist der CO2
auch hat ist sehr schwer es im Vergleich
zum Leopard 2 ich formuliere das mal
vorsichtig etwas unbeweglicher aber es
ist ein durchaus leistungsstarker
Kampfpanzer der schweren Klasse ich bin
immer vorsichtig mit der Definition
schwere Klasse leichte Klasse oder spät
Panzer und dergleichen mehr weil das
möglicherweise Art zu ja der Möglichkeit
führt bestimmt einen Aussagen
auszuweichen und ich möchte das
eigentlich vermeiden auch gegenüber der
Politik
noch eine Frage zu den Panzern kam per
Mail von Florian
Briten verfügen bei diesem Kampfpanzer
etwa über eine Größenordnung von ich
sage mal rund 260 sie haben 200 in der
Nutzung beim Royal Armatur von daher sie
haben im Gegensatz zu uns wenn Sie so
wollen Größenordnung 60 übrig die man
theoretisch abgeben könnte
eine allgemeine Frage zu Kampfpanzern
kam von Florian per Mail der sich fragte
wie viele Kampfpanzer benötigt die
Ukraine um die russischen Truppen vom
Staatsgebiet zu verdrängen
also es ist nicht möglich hier eine
konkrete Zahl zu nennen weil ich auch
nicht weiß wie viele Kampfpanzer die
russische Seite jetzt sage ich ganz
bewusst noch im Einsatz hat oder im
Einsatz bringen kann als wir mit dem
Krieg angefangen haben am 24 februar die
Aggression der Russen begann verfügte
die russische Seite etwa über 1100
Kampfpanzer davon sind viele zerstört
worden davon sind einige auch in die
Hände der Ukrainer gefallen aber ich
habe im Augenblick auch aufgrund der
schlechten
Informationen mangelhaften Informationen
von russischer Seite her keinen
Überblick wie viel von dieser Zahl
Panzer die ich gerade genannt habe jetzt
noch übrig sind darüber muss man sich
einfach im Klaren sein und sie können
auch mit modernen Nachrichten Mitteln
Satelliten Aufklärung im vergleichbaren
der vergleichbaren Sachen nicht auf dem
Gefechtsfeld Panzer zählen das
funktioniert nicht dann schauen wir
jetzt noch mal auf den Kriegsverlauf
denn es gibt auch immer wieder kursieren
Befürchtungen das ist einen neuen
Angriff russischer Truppen aus Belarus
geben könnte vor zwei Tagen angekündigte
das belarussische
Verteidigungsministerium nämlich ein
luftwaffenmanöver mit Russland Mitte
Januar an und jetzt zeigen wir auch
Bilder wir haben Bilder von Machthaber
in Belarus Lukaschenko der nämlich am
Freitag eine gemeinsame Einsatztruppe
der beiden Länder besucht hatte
offiziell so sagen das Russland und
Belarus gilt die also zum Schutz der
Grenzen deshalb wurde sie aufgestellt
und in Belarus das ist aber auch
interessant sollen dafür 9000 russische
Soldaten stationiert sein da stellt sich
natürlich die Frage wäre denn so eine
neue Offensive aus dem Norden aus
Belarus theoretisch denkbar wäre das
möglich
also der Präsident Lukaschenko ist ein
ja wie soll ich mal sagen Schlitzohr auf
der einen Seite und dann cleveres
Kerlchen auf der anderen Seite
wir wissen dass vor dem vor dem Angriff
vor der Aggression Russlands am 24
februar ist ebenfalls gemeinsame Übungen
auch von Landstreitkräften also
heeresübungen im Belarus gegeben hat auf
den dortigen Übungsplätzen wir wissen
dass Lukaschenko der russischen Seite
Flugplätze und auch Basen zur Verfügung
stellt aber ich muss feststellen an
dieser Stelle ganz deutlich und
eindeutig das ist bisher keinen Bella
russischen Soldaten gibt der die Grenze
zur Ukraine überschritten hat auch die
Formulierung diese gemeinsame diese 9000
Soldaten russischen Soldaten die in
Belarus jetzt stationiert sind zum
Schutz der Grenze ist auch eine sehr
interessante Formulierung weil dieses
andeutet ja wenn Kiew oder die Ukraine
uns angreifen würde würde uns die
russischen Partner dabei stehen aber
diese Formulierung enthält nicht die
Aussage
nach dem Motto wir greifen jetzt
gemeinsam mit den Russen an ich glaube
dass Lukaschenko in zwei Richtungen
denkt in dieser in diesem Falle oder
grundsätzlich in seiner politischen
Linie denkt sehr genau darüber nach wie
weit er den Russen Unterstützung
zukommen lassen kann und der denkt aber
offensichtlich auch schon ein bisschen
weiter dass er möglicherweise ihm diese
Sache nicht reingezogen werden will
einfach aus dem Grunde weil es ja auch
möglich sein kann dass Russland so hoffe
ich den Krieg verliert und dann wäre
Lukaschenko mit auf der Verliererseite
und wenn das passieren sollte könnte er
jetzt argumentieren ich habe mich an
diesem Krieg nicht beteiligt ja ich habe
Basen zur Verfügung gestellt ich habe
Flughäfen zur Verfügung gestellt aber
ich habe keine weißrussischen Soldaten
in die Ukraine
aber ganz grundsätzlich neue offensiven
von russischer Seite ist das etwas was
Sie also in naher Zukunft sehen ganz
unmittelbar manche Experten experten
sprechen ja von der Möglichkeit im
Frühling wie sehen Sie das
also ich bin im Augenblick damit
vorsichtig ich bin einfach aus dem
Grunde vorsichtig weil ich nicht
ermessen kann und weiß inwieweit Putin
weitere Rekrutierung in Russland
durchführt und weil ich im Moment nicht
weiß welche Truppenteile er aus Russland
noch in die Ukraine führen könnte um sie
dort in die Gefechte einzuführen ich
sehe den russischen Schwerpunkt zur Zeit
im Osten und dafür spricht auch die also
die Situation die wir gerade besprochen
haben hinsichtlich der Situation in
Solidar und in backum von daher sage ich
mal haben wir dort eine Situation wo die
Russen ihre Kräfte Ausbauten könnten
wenn sie dort entsprechende Erfolge
haben das wird im Süden mit Blick auf
Person vor allen Dingen den jepper
deutlich schwieriger weil man dafür
diesen Fluss wieder überwinden muss von
daher hat die Ukraine dort unten einen
Vorteil und kann möglicherweise dort mit
einem geringen Aufwand von Kräften
verteidigen so dass sie möglicherweise
auch bei einem verstärkten russischen
Angriff oder weitere Angriff im Osten
die Kräfte von dort aus vom Süden her
ihre eigenen Kräfte verstärken kann aber
das sind schon ein bisschen Dinge wo ich
sage da muss man jetzt schon fast eine
Glaskugel haben um zu sagen wie sich das
Ganze weiterentwickeln wird und ich
möchte in der Richtung eigentlich nicht
spekulieren wichtig ist dass die Ukraine
in jeder Beziehung tüchtigt wird sich
selber zu verteidigen dafür braucht sie
die entsprechenden Waffen die
entsprechende Munition die entsprechende
Unterstützung und ohnedem wird es nicht
gehen ich vergleiche die Ukraine mal mit
einem Patienten der sich schwer
infiziert hat und der jetzt an einem
Topf fängt mit einem Antibiotikum um
entsprechend zu überleben und vielleicht
auch entsprechend geheilt werden zu
können das genau die Situation die wir
im Bild haben müssen wenn wir von der
westlichen Unterstützung für die Ukraine
reden denn wir müssen die Ukraine
unterstützen sonst stellen wir den Topf
ab und dann dürfte es für die Ukraine
ausgesprochen schwierig werden
und wir haben unsere Sendung begonnen
mit der Lage um bachmut und Solidar und
jetzt zum Schluss möchte ich das auch
noch mal aufgreifen denn hier kam eine
Frage bei Youtube von Alfred Steinacher
der sich fragte sollte bachmut
eingenommen werden von russischer Seite
eben was heißt das dann für den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf
das heißt für den weiteren Kriegsverlauf
dass die Ukraine gezwungen ist in diesem
Bereich ihre Kräfte zu verstärken um den
Angriff der Russen a aufzufangen wenn er
stattfindet oder wenn er weitere Erfolge
zeigt oder Erfolge zeigt und zum zweiten
braucht die Ukraine dann das hatte ich
vorhin schon mal angedeutet zusätzliche
Kräfte um diese Gelände Gewinne der
Russen dann wieder rückgängig zu machen
denn es ist ja nach wie vor das erklärte
Ziel des Präsidenten und der
ukrainischen Regierung die durch die
Terroristen wie selinski immer sagt
besetzten Gebiete entsprechend
zurückzuerobern und wenn die Russen
tatsächlich vor marschieren könnten was
ich nicht glaube würde das auch jede Art
von Verhandlungssituation für die
Ukraine zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
erheblich verschlechtern das heißt wir
müssen auch da politisch denken müssen
über politische Unterstützung nachdenken
in dieser Richtung und vielleicht auch
im Auge behalten dass die Ukraine
diejenigen sind die letztendlich
bestimmen wann über bestimmte Dinge
verhandelt wird oder ob Verhandlungen
überhaupt beginnen zur Zeit stehen sich
die beiden Maximalziele von der
russischen Seite her Auflösung der
Ukraine unter dem Stichwort
Entnazifizierung und anderer völlig
fehlgegriffener Dinge und Rückeroberung
des gesamten ukrainischen Gebietes ja
diametral gegenüber und ich sehe
dazwischen auch noch keine Einigung
das passt gut zur allerletzten Frage
dieser Sendung Stichwort Verhandlungen
denn dort das Scanner bei Youtube möchte
konkret von Ihnen wissen was müsste
ihrer Meinung nach passieren damit der
Konflikt beigelegt werden kann was
müsste unternommen werden um den
Konflikt schnell und friedlich
beizulegen
also der Konflikt muss beigelegt werden
er muss beigelegt werden und zu einem
Frieden führen aber die einzige Chance
die ich dafür zurzeit sehe ist die
Tatsache dass wir die Ukraine von
unserer Seite ja so ertüchtigen dass sie
in der Lage ist die Russen auf ihrem
Territorium auf dem völkerrechtswidrig
annektierten der Ukraine zu schlagen
es braucht offensichtlich starker
Erschütterung für die russische Seite um
eine entsprechende
Verhandlungsbereitschaft zu zeigen und
von ihren maximalzielen abzugehen von
daher ist das Thema Verhandlungen im
Augenblick für mich ein schwieriges
Thema und es ist auch schwierig für die
Ukraine denn nachgeben heißt für die
russische Seite immer Schwäche das ist
nicht neu das ist nicht jetzt sondern
das ist immer schon so gewesen von der
russischen Seite her das hat
Ausnahmezeiten gegeben zu
bürgerschaftszeiten und jetzt sind
Zeiten aber die sind leider seit mehr
als 20 Jahren vorbei
sagt general ade Egon Rams auch vielen
Dank heute wieder für ihre Einschätzung
und für ihre Zeit dass ihr bei uns zu
Gast waren danke
gerne ich bedanke mich auch
und danke natürlich auch für eure Zeit
für eure Fragen ich habe einen Kommentar
gerade noch gesehen bei Youtube den
möchte ich gerne zum Ende Vorlesen da
schreibt jemand ich wünsche mir Frieden
aber wer tut das nicht manchmal sind die
einfachsten Dinge am schwersten und
damit schließen wir diese Sendung und
freuen uns auf das nächste Mal wenn ihr
dabei seid bis dahin tschüss